Sous-titrage Société Radio-Canada
Homage to the Buddha, the blessed noble and fully self-enlightened.
This evening, I just want to talk about the mind,
ce soir j'aimerais simplement parler de l'esprit, en particulier du langage, du concept, etc. Peut-être plus tard parler un petit peu de ces états mentaux avec les
Dans la psychologie bouddhiste, à chaque fois qu'un ressenti apparaît, une perception apparaît en même temps.
Quand nous disons qu'un ressenti apparaît dans le bouddhisme, nous voulons dire qu'il y a six portes sensibles.
Quand nous parlons de l'apparition de la ressentie, nous faisons référence aussi aux six portes des sens.
Il y a évidemment les cinq sens que nous connaissons.
Par exemple, quand un photon entre en contact avec la rétine, ce qui se produit à ce moment-là, dans la psychologie bouddhiste, c'est une sensation.
Et quand les ondes d'air pressent sur l'oreille, c'est le point de contact.
C'est ce qu'on appelle un contact.
Et le 6ème sens, c'est le esprit-coeur lui-même.
Dans le bouddhisme, quand nous parlons de l'esprit, nous traduisons le mot chitta.
Mais en fait, la véritable traduction serait le cœur et l'esprit.
Il n'y avait pas à l'époque encore ce clivage récent entre
Même dans l'Ouest maintenant, quand ils disent qu'ils pensent, ils pointent à leur cœur.
Mais pour nous, ces deux choses sont devenues très distinctes.
Mais ce que nous commençons à réaliser dans notre méditation, c'est que quand la pensée arrive, le cœur se déplace.
nous commençons à réaliser dans la méditation, c'est que quand des pensées apparaissent, le cœur est aussi ébranlé, mis en mouvement.
Et quand le cœur se met en mouvement, l'esprit se met aussi en mouvement.
L'un réagit à l'autre.
Donc maintenant, si nous prenons un exemple très simple, une pomme.
Quand nous dégustons une pomme pour la première fois, parce que c'est complètement nouveau, nous sommes complètement saisis par la pomme, par le goût de la pomme.
Ah, c'est ça.
C'est ce que nous observons chez les tout petits enfants.
Quand vous observez un enfant qui chante quelque chose pour la première fois, observez vraiment son visage.
Parce qu'il nous dit...
Ils avaient une photo d'un enfant qui chante alors que c'était une photo d'un enfant qui voit quelque chose.
C'était mignon.
Si vous étudiez le visage d'un enfant quand il voit quelque chose de nouveau, cela nous dit quelque chose
cette Satipanya dans son état d'origine donc nous disions ce matin que Sati c'est cette conscience ouverte qui accepte tout ce qui vient et dans cette conscience il y a cette intelligence intuitive
Et au sein de cette attention, de cette conscience, il y a cette intelligence intuitive qui se saisit de l'objet et qui le comprend.
Ce ne sont pas deux facultés distinctes.
C'est la même en recevant et en voyant.
C'est la même au moment de la réception et de la vision, de la perception.
Quand un enfant regarde quelque chose de nouveau, vous verrez que ses yeux sont complètement fixés.
Il est complètement absorbé en observant cette petite espèce de espèce.
Il est complètement absorbé par l'observation de cette araignée.
Fourmi.
Grosse fourmi.
Oh là là.
Ah, bienvenue.
Donc nous avons les yeux fixés sur l'objet qui nous dit qu'ils sont complètement concentrés.
Mais la mâchoire est complètement relâchée et elles regardent quelque chose avec leur bouche ouverte.
De notre point de vue, elles sont gormelles.
Vous dites gormelles en anglais, comment vous traduisez gormelles ?
Elles semblent stupides.
donc on leur donne un coup sur la tête et on leur dit réveille-toi quelqu'un me disait que quand elle avait cet âge-là et qu'elle était dans cet état son père lui disait ferme ta bouche et une mouche va rentrer de cette façon
nous avons ruiné ce enfant d'obtenir une libération immédiate.
Malheureusement, de cette manière, nous avons supprimé toute chance pour cet enfant d'atteindre immédiatement l'éveil.
Et nous, bien sûr, nous-mêmes, avons eu la même misfortune.
Évidemment, il nous est arrivé exactement la même chose que nous étions enfants, malheureusement.
Donc, cette qualité de la bouche complètement relaxée nous dit qu'il n'y a pas de langage.
Cette qualité de la marche d'or totalement relâchée nous indique qu'il n'y a pas de langage.
Dans votre méditation, si vous surprenez votre esprit en train de penser, vous faites porter votre attention sur la bouche, vous sentirez une petite vibration.
Parce que la pensée est vécue incarnée physiquement.
Donc maintenant, une fois que nous avons goûté un oiseau, une fois que nous avons goûté un oiseau, il y a une image faite de cela dans la tête.
une fois que nous avons dégusté une pomme il y a une image de ceci qui a été faite dans notre esprit c'est à la fois une image émotionnelle affective que nous attachons à une pomme généralement c'est de la joie mais pas forcément et aussi une image une image mentale
Il y a aussi une image mentale dans l'esprit de ce à quoi ressemble une pomme.
À partir de là, à chaque fois que nous mangeons une pomme, nous ajustons cette base sensorielle, cette perception ressentie.
jusqu'à ce que nous ayons finalement dans notre esprit la pomme parfaite donc à partir de là chaque pomme que nous mangeons est jugée à l'aune de cette pomme parfaite donc à partir de là
à partir du moment où nous mangeons une pomme nous sommes déjà en train de séparer distinguer ces goûts que nous voulons sentir pour qu'ils soient conformes à notre idée d'une pomme et donc c'est impossible pour moi de déguster cette pomme telle qu'elle est
Maintenant, cette idée que je suis en train de déguster la pomme telle qu'elle est, c'est vraiment une profonde illusion.
Ce que je suis en train de goûter, c'est la manière dont ma bouche et ma langue font l'expérience de cette pomme.
Le nez est le nez.
Quand nous commençons à investiguer notre expérience de cette manière, nous prenons conscience que nous-mêmes créons le monde dans lequel nous vivons.
It has some reflection or contact with the world as it is.
It has some form of contact or reality with the world as it is.
But it's never exactly as it is.
It's entirely dependent upon my sense bases,
et même la culture dans laquelle je vis notre intention dans la méditation c'est de retourner à ce esprit comme un enfant
Notre intention dans la méditation, c'est de revenir à cet état d'esprit de l'enfant.
Le principal obstacle que nous avons, c'est ces concepts que nous avons formés dans l'esprit et dans le cœur.
All that conceptual ideas to a single idea.
Le fait de noter a au moins l'avantage de rassembler toutes ces idées conceptuelles dans un mot unique.
Une idée unique.
So, when I'm tasting the food, for instance, the chocolate that you had for a break, you see.
Par exemple, si vous dégustez le chocolat que vous avez eu tout à l'heure.
So, whether I like it or not, I'm judging this chocolate, hein.
que ça me plaise ou pas, je suis en train de juger ce chocolat.
Si je veux pouvoir déguster ce chocolat comme un enfant, avec l'esprit d'un enfant, je dois pouvoir résumer tout le...
Tous les processus intellectuels en un seul mot, en une seule lettre.
C'est par le simple fait de dire, je goûte, goûter, goûter, je stoppe le processus de l'esprit qui en fait penser, penser.
cette conscience intuitive est confusée en pensant que c'est une pensée je vais essayer encore une fois
Cette conscience intuitive pense que c'est une pensée.
Cette conscience intuitive pense qu'elle est une pensée.
Oui, que c'est une pensée, que c'est une pensée.
Maintenant, quand je dis « goûter, goûter », je suis conscient de ce mot « goûter, goûter ».
Quand je dis goûter, goûter, j'ai conscience de ce mot, goûter, goûter.
Ce qui signifie que cette intelligence intuitive s'est extraite de la pensée.
En s'extrayant de la pensée de cette manière, elle est libre de mettre son attention sur le ressenti.
Vous voyez ?
Quand cette conscience intuitive se porte sur le ressenti, elle se libère de son histoire.
Parce que l'histoire contient les mots et les concepts.
Histoire est contenue dans nos pensées et notre raisonnement conceptuel et notre imagination.
Maintenant, cette conscience intuitive est capable d'identifier, de voir les ressentis de façon claire.
Et c'est à ce niveau, au moment où elle peut les voir, qu'on commence
On peut voir comment notre esprit crève.
En mangeant, mon attention est sur les sensations de la langue.
Si mon attention est là, je peux commencer à sentir comment le cœur répond.
Donc, comme la nourriture nous a touchés à l'heure du déjeuner, vous voyez,
l'émerveillement qui apparaît autour de la nourriture.
Une forme de délice, de satisfaction.
C'est correct.
Nous devons encourager les cuisines.
Donc,
Cette réaction est conditionnée par les expériences précédentes avec le passé.
Et en plus de ça, il y a le processus de désirer quelque chose.
Et le désir nous pousse à continuer de renforcer le processus de goût.
Et en faisant cela, nous continuons de recréer le moment.
Vous voyez ?
Donc, cela nous dit comment nous
ça nous indique comment nous créons le monde pour nous-mêmes le processus de goûter le processus de goûter quelque chose la réponse du cœur
Et le processus de désirer est complètement naturel.
C'est complètement naturel.
C'est aussi ce qui est arrivé au Bouddha.
Où faisons-nous faux ?
C'est une mauvaise compréhension de là où nous pouvons trouver notre bonheur.
Si vous vous demandez ce que vous voulez vraiment, je pense que vous serez d'accord avec le mot « bonheur ».
Tout le monde définira le bonheur différemment, mais ils veulent le bonheur.
Donc, dans notre recherche pour être heureux, nous nous attaquons à des choses mentales, nous les attachons à elles.
Dans notre désir d'être heureux, nous nous agrippons, nous nous attachons à des choses sur le plan mental.
Et comme nous le disions ce matin, cela a produit des problèmes pour nous.
Notre but, c'est de revenir à cet état d'esprit d'enfant et d'expérimenter des choses juste au niveau de l'expérience pure.
faire l'expérience des choses à un niveau purement expérientiel.
La personne la plus sensuelle du monde est quelqu'un qui est libéré.
Oui, parce que son expérience de vie
ou son expérience de vie, n'est pas détournée par l'expérience passée.
Chaque expérience vient comme quelque chose de complètement nouveau.
L'histoire n'impose pas
une vue particulière sur une situation particulière.
C'est pourquoi nous devons arrêter notre esprit.
Quand vous lisez la littérature zen, vous vous rendez compte de la phrase « pas d'esprit ».
Si vous lisez la littérature zen, vous trouverez la phrase « pas d'esprit ».
Ce que ça veut en fait dire, c'est pas de pensée, pas d'imagination.
Quand cette pensée s'arrête, même si c'est juste pour un instant, si vous attrapez un train de pensées, et à ce moment-là, ça s'arrête,
si vous arrivez à saisir un train de pensée à ce moment il s'arrête c'est cet intervalle avant que le prochain train de pensée démarre qui est la pure intelligence intuitive du pur satipan maintenant
même si nous disons que le problème est dans la relation que nous avons, le désir et les attachements le problème à l'origine réside justement dans cette conscience intuitive parce que c'est un erreur
Le erreur, c'est de croire qu'elle est un être humain.
Maintenant, conventionnellement, nous sommes des êtres humains.
Nous ne sommes pas des êtres humains.
Mais, bien sûr, ce erreur de penser que nous sommes des êtres humains, de chercher la bonheur,
Mais cette erreur de penser que nous sommes des êtres humains, qui cherchons le bonheur dans cette forme humaine, ça c'est vraiment un problème.
Le Bouddha parle de ce désir constant de chercher ça et là.
Je vous ai parlé de comment l'esprit cherche constamment du bonheur et évidemment à éviter de fuir la douleur.
Quand nous faisons une méditation assise nous nous ouvrons à notre vie interne.
Et ce que nous trouvons normalement horribles choses
parce que c'est la turbulence qui monte à la surface c'est comme enlever le couvercle d'une coupe c'est comme enlever le couvercle d'une coupe donc maintenant nous avons ce problème
toute cette douleur qui apparaît, qu'elle soit physique ou émotionnelle.
La réponse appropriée, c'est de ne pas y réagir.
Nous y réagissons en cherchant à le pousser à l'écart ou en l'ignorant.
et même en le poussant ou en le tournant avec peur.
Donc, de cette position de croire que je suis un être humain, je crée trois attitudes fondamentales.
La première est cette acquisitivité
gathering things.
This, I feel more safe if I have lots of money in the bank.
I feel happier if I have lots of friends.
So, the acquisitiveness begins to turn into greed.
Now, once I have attached to something,
une fois qu'on s'est attaché à quelque chose, il faut que je le défende, que je le protège.
Parce que vous voulez probablement la même chose que moi.
Et là apparaît évidemment mon aversion, mon agression, mon agressivité.
Et si vous êtes plus grand que moi, alors il faut que je coure.
Avec tous mes sacs pleins de toutes mes choses.
Donc,
These are our three basic dispositions.
Acquisitiveness, aversion and fear.
And from this, whatever actions we produce are going to be unwholesome.
I'll become more inquisitive, more averse, more fearful.
Et on a une encore plus forte tendance à accumuler davantage de peur et d'aversion.
Ces turbulences sont classifiées par le Bouddha en 5 types différents.
Les premières sont toutes celles que nous appréhendons.
La première, c'est toutes ces choses que nous apprécions.
Rappelez-vous que ce n'est pas la chose en soi, c'est la relation que nous avons avec elle.
C'est le désir, c'est le caractère obsessionnel.
Si vous vous trouvez en train de planifier ces vacances, planifier ces vacances, planifier ces vacances, c'est le signe que vous êtes en train de devenir obsédé par le désir de ces vacances.
C'est la raison pour laquelle nous notons en planification et nous revenons ensuite.
Maintenant, quand nous revenons,
Nous revenons à la respiration.
Mais en revenant à la respiration, je peux sentir dans le corps cette agitation.
Et là, je me tourne vers l'agitation.
Je m'assieds en plein milieu de cette agitation.
Je permets à l'agitation de se manifester complètement.
Si j'ai une aversion à être là, je note l'aversion.
Si c'est très inconfortable, je note l'aversion, l'aversion.
Et je reste très stille dans cette matrice.
C'est la matrice.
Vous avez donc cette émotion, cette turbulence, et vous avez le ne pas vouloir.
Vous placez votre attention en plein milieu.
Et vous permettez que le feu se brûle.
Vous autorisez au feu de brûler.
Si vous pouvez rester jusqu'à ce qu'il se soit éteint lui-même, qu'il ait brûlé jusqu'au bout, jusqu'à la fin, vous noterez que l'esprit a arrêté sa planification.
Ça, ça nous dit que l'esprit est
Et plus nous sommes convaincus de cela, plus nous ferons cet effort de rester avec le cœur dans cette turbulence.
C'est la même chose avec toutes les choses que nous n'aimons pas.
C'est la deuxième catégorie.
les colères et toutes ces choses c'est exactement la même chose vous notez simplement ce que vous êtes en train de faire vous argumentez et vous revenez au coeur le ressenti si il n'y a pas de ressenti, parfait vous revenez à la respiration
Et si vous le faites assez souvent, le ressenti va éventuellement sortir du corps.
Et si vous le refaites à chaque fois, finalement le ressenti va se manifester dans le corps.
Et si nous ne le ressentons pas, cela signifie que cette énergie va directement dans la pensée.
nous ne le sentons pas, c'est que cette énergie est en train de se diriger directement, se manifester sous forme de pensée souvent quand vous parlez à des gens, ils vous diront qu'ils se sentent fâchés dans leur tête ils sentent la dépression dans leur tête, pas dans le corps donc si la personne continue de sortir de la pensée éventuellement, ces sentiments vont sortir du corps
Si une personne à chaque fois se détache de l'esprit en sang, finalement ses ressentis vont se manifester dans le corps.
Si vous restez simplement là et que vous développez de la patience et de la colère.
Quand l'esprit est pris dans ses pensées, vouloir ou ne pas vouloir,
Et vous notez, vous voyez, planification, argumentation.
Quand vous revenez au corps, vous pouvez sentir cette turbulence.
Restez un peu lourd autour de ça.
Oui, juste, vous savez, généralement, dans, mais lourd.
Vous observez ce ressenti, mais d'une manière relâchée.
Vous pouvez prendre conscience alors que c'est ce petit peu d'énergie qui veut s'échapper.
Pour moi, c'est toujours de cette façon.
Ne me demandez pas pourquoi.
C'est le chemin vers l'esprit.
Si vous pouvez simplement attendre jusqu'à ce que ça baisse, alors l'esprit s'arrête.
L'autre, c'est l'agitation.
Ça peut être aussi physique.
Quand c'est physique, une bonne idée, c'est de commencer du haut de la tête, et juste faire votre chemin vers les pieds.
faire votre chemin avec votre attention jusqu'au bas du corps.
Et observer quelles sont les parties du corps qui sont vraiment agitées et quelles sont celles qui ne le sont pas.
Je ne me suis jamais senti agité au bout de mon nez.
Et l'attention est tellement submergée par cette agitation que nous nous perdons dedans.
Par exemple, il y a beaucoup d'agitation dans vos mains.
Restez simplement avec cette agitation.
Déplacez votre attention autour.
Et attendez que cette énergie s'épuise d'elle-même.
Quand il s'agit de l'esprit qui...
il pense simplement à rien il y a simplement beaucoup d'énergie vous avez l'impression de devenir dingue j'ai bien peur que dans ce cas là la seule chose que vous puissiez faire c'est de continuer à noter à chaque fois que vous en sortez et à chaque fois ramener votre attention
Et c'est tout ce que vous pouvez faire, à mon avis.
Ensuite, il y a le doute.
Maintenant, l'attitude que nous devons avoir est celle d'enquêter.
L'attitude que nous devons avoir, c'est une attitude d'investigation.
Croire en tout ce que le Bouddha a dit serait un obstacle.
Parce que c'est le processus d'investigation qui est le processus de la libération.
Si vous vous prosterniez cent mille fois,
Et chaque fois que vous vous bowez, vous dites, je crois dans le Bouddha.
Je crois dans la souffrance et dans la fin de la souffrance.
Ça ne vous aiderait pas du tout.
La toute chose que le Bouddha nous met, c'est une théorie.
Et c'est pour nous de la rendre vraie pour nous.
Cette attitude d'investigation est indispensable.
L'attitude philosophique d'émerveillement.
C'est ça ?
D'émerveillement.
Donc c'est nécessaire.
on se demande comment
Qu'est-ce qui fait que la terre tourne ?
Ça c'est nécessaire.
Mais le doute qui n'est pas nécessaire est appelé le doute sceptique.
Le doute sceptique n'émerge pas d'un pur désir de vouloir connaître, comprendre.
Il émerge de peur.
Il émerge à partir de...
Il sort de la peur.
Quand nous, par exemple, allons chercher un travail, quand nous cherchons du travail, quand nous allons chercher un travail, il y a dans nous le doute sur si je peux faire ce travail ou non.
Il y a en nous le doute, est-ce que je peux faire ce travail ou pas ?
Si c'est véritablement du doute, nous irons et nous accepterons le travail.
Mais si c'est un doute sceptique, ça va nous bloquer, ça va nous empêcher de le faire.
Parce que nous commençons à faire des listes.
Pour le travail, contre le travail.
Et on hésite toujours.
Et en même temps que vous faites ça, pour passer du temps à faire ça, le travail est finalement attribué à quelqu'un d'autre.
Il est encore pire s'il s'agit d'une relation romane
Si vous voulez aller plus loin, oui, non, non, oui, la personne elle s'en va.
Ce doute sceptique est pernicieux dans notre vie, il nous empêche de faire des choses.
Si vous souffrez de ça, ce qu'il vous faut faire, évidemment, c'est aller dans la bouche du lion.
Ah !
Tout d'un coup, on y va, on le fait.
Il s'agit souvent d'une peur de l'échec.
Ça, c'est les quatre obstacles, c'est comme ça qu'ils les appellent, qui sont actifs.
Et il faut avoir nos stratégies pour les surmonter, vous voyez.
Nos techniques pour les surmonter.
Nos tactiques.
C'est une guerre.
Et le dernier, c'est la torpeur et la léthargie.
Donc,
Les précédents, c'est une espèce de tempête.
Tout bien.
C'est plutôt un siphon qui nous attire dans un doux oubli.
Et ce qui est merveilleux avec cet oubli, c'est qu'il n'y a pas de souffrance associée.
Et nous l'utilisons pour échapper à la souffrance.
Combien de fois avez-vous été assis ?
Un peu déprimé.
Et vous vous êtes jeté sur le canapé.
Et puis il y a le délire d'être dans ce état subliminal.
Et là, il y a le délice de se trouver dans cet état subliminal.
On se réveille, on prend une tasse de thé et on retourne.
On lit le journal et on s'en va.
C'est un... Lotus Eaters.
C'est un... Ne vous inquiétez pas.
C'est un...
Et là, notre stratégie, c'est un refus total d'être anéanti.
Quelles que soient les circonstances.
Rappelez-vous que les deux ou trois premiers jours de chaque retraite sont toujours un petit peu traités.
Mais après le troisième jour, il n'y a plus aucune excuse.
Il ne peut plus y avoir de fatigue.
Notre effort, c'est de rester réveillé.
Au moment où vous sentez cette léthargie, cette torpeur qui monte dans la tête, ne vous faites pas confiance.
Ne pensez pas que ça va passer, ou que ce n'est pas vraiment beaucoup.
Vraiment, vous savez, ringuez l'alarme.
Ah, réveillez-vous.
Ouvrez les yeux.
Mais votre attention est sur le ressenti dans la tête.
Et gardez votre attention dans votre cerveau.
gardez votre attention en mouvement à l'intérieur de votre cerveau et vous remarquerez que vous pouvez vous réveiller au milieu de ces nuages aussi brillants que le soleil parce que l'énergie est retenue dans le regard
parce que l'énergie revient à l'observation et cela se passe parce que l'observation s'extrait de ces sensations avec lesquelles elle se confondait c'est-à-dire qu'elle se confond
Elle est attirée par l'habitude vers cet oubli cotonneux.
Vous vous réveillerez comme une ampoule électrique au milieu de ce porridge.
Et l'esprit peut être en pleine forme, mais le corps peut se sentir vraiment fatigué, sommeil.
Et donc, il nous faut aussi faire l'effort physique.
Et garder l'attention en mouvement autour du corps.
Faire savoir quelles parties du corps se sentent lourdes et dormantes et quelles ne le sont pas.
Vous trouvez quelles sont les parties du corps qui se sentent lourdes et somnolentes et lesquelles ne se sentent pas.
Et encore une fois, vous découvrirez probablement que le bout de votre nez ne veut jamais dormir.
Et simplement en déplaçant votre attention, vous redonnez de l'énergie
Donc, avec chaque de ces hindrances, il y a des techniques particulières que nous pouvons utiliser pour ne pas nous laisser prendre dans ces obstacles.
Et donc, nous pouvons les investiguer.
Maintenant, pendant que nous faisons cela, ce...
Et pendant que nous faisons cette investigation, ces turbulences s'épuisent d'elles-mêmes.
Ça, c'est la thérapie.
Une fois que vous comprenez ça, ça va sauver.
Vous économisez beaucoup d'argent.
Personne n'est un thérapeute ici.
C'est ce qu'il espère.
Même si c'est évident que toutes les thérapies modernes sont très très bien faisantes.
Selon la perspective de cette libération de la souffrance, ce n'est pas nécessaire.
Si vous preniez cette pratique et que vous l'ameniez dans votre vie quotidienne, vous observeriez une guérison du cœur ?
Ce qui ne veut pas dire que la thérapie ne peut pas accompagner aussi ce processus.
Ce soir, nous discutons vraiment du côté négatif de la pratique.
Comment gérer cette souffrance.
Une bonne partie d'entre vous nous quitteront demain.
Et malheureusement, vous manquerez donc mon discours sur à quel point la vie peut être merveilleuse.
Il est possible que vous vous quittiez déprimé.
Avec rien d'autre dans votre esprit que cette terrible bataille contre les forcins.
après le repas du midi je ferai une longue pratique de Metta j'espère qu'elle vous permettra de développer le bel esprit
J'espère que mes mots vous ont aidé.
Dans votre guerre incessante contre les hostages.
J'ai prié que vous soyez libérés de toute souffrance.
Plutôt que plus tard.
Le plus tôt possible.